hello and welcome to this video playing
you Katya with black know do something
sharp okay you three that's a kind of
saying you want something sharp I don't
sort of bad news extremely healthy no
couldn't play P sex maybe okay man now
I'm happy to take with b3 signaling his
intention to put addition on to be to
and going into a hanging confirmation
it's not really yeah it's not really
what you want here with the white let's
see a shop here not before so a three is
probably necessary if you go see for now
there is a couple of things 94 in
particular night h5 is also an
interesting try to go chair forward I
will just do this and ask white for next
smooth it's not that clear cannot take
SD for almost almost raw it's not quite
dropping but close and my next move
would be not going to be six roopd aid
putting pressure on the deep on yeah
white has absolutely no opening
advantage whatsoever
let's see what he does
it's not not really clear what his move
is something like rookie one has to go
Queen b6 the whole white setup is very
passive and in particular against Wow
against a fianchetto against a fear
kettle set up it's it's very passive so
how do you keep you 5 here
guess you don't look at the rookie age
when a seven is attacked it's not it's
not really super important another move
that is interesting here is just Bishop
h6 then taking on c2
okay I'm just going to play it in a very
simple fashion maybe he's got g-form
didn't take that into account
it would have been interesting actually
mm-hmm um that move is extremely strange
wait what is that doing okay it takes
the a pawn
take-take-take say seven still at Bishop
age six
isn't that also quite a bit of an
annoying double attack so I check here
okay yeah that is not a problem I think
okay so I mean I can take with the
bishop it's got Queen deform but I
thought f6 actually was what's the move
yeah that's go f6
and okay look I'm a five or is there
anything even better here well let's do
that Quincy form it's just about saving
this one may be threatening Queen chicks
and then taking the rook my drugs you
wanna take it's not easy now if I'm to
make a move at least I don't see a great
one
so my tf2
[Music]
don't really see a problem with that so
let's check and then I take here weight
made with the rook is saying wait I can
take the rook home it's no reason not to
check the hook that was a bit of an
opening opening disaster yeah after b3
that is the signal move for me to take
because with b3 shows that he wants to
basically put it on b2 and then the
trade makes a lot of sense as the bishop
is just passive on b2 I mean it's not
terrible it's just White has absolutely
no active plane he it's not easy to
order to do something constructive
Knight takes e4 doesn't work but so not
much fun c4 maybe yeah yeah I just
wonder if I had even something better
Bishop h6 was suggested by the computer
yeah he and I he's got reform that that
I was already worried about that during
the game at least that is not the best
possible scenario for me no I mean if he
wins that was no if he wins it let's say
here here here I'm sorry
here here here I will always have
compensation because the king is a bit
open and my pieces are quite active but
that it's not what I wanted so here I
should play Bishop h6
position is that this is just no problem
I go f6 and stop everything
so g4 was an opportunity and now I hope
I didn't give him any more
III with rook c5 is not bad
he 606 should be okay now III is a good
move
just tactically motivated try to take
check on v1 and then the week is gone if
he plays better like this
I'm just trading this this take a three
look g8 a spatula okay they I would have
taken a three I guess that was a dis my
plan it's two pawns and no real
compensation for what okay guys thanks
for watching